alright guys bangbang what's up we've
come people to get in here but long
story short is I'm gonna spend the next
hour or so trying to talk through
whether I think the economic price is
going to get worse before I think it's
gonna get better and in order to be able
to do that let's first start just with
where are we I think is an important
place to start so if you remember kind
of end of fede really we had one of if
not the best economic situations in the
United States that we've ever had and we
saw record low unemployment we saw stock
market highs every single thing that was
going on just seemed to point to a very
strong economy a very robust economy and
one that for the most part didn't seem
like it was going to slow down if you go
back though there were a number of
economic alarm bells that had gone off
late last year
everything from inverted yield curves to
a high number of corporate CEOs leaving
their jobs and so there was definitely
signs that look we're in the longest
bull market in history it is likely not
to go on forever
but we don't know when that's going to
end or what's going to be kind of the
accelerant that that really kind of
turns over the market and so obviously
coronavirus occurs and even at the end
of February I don't think a lot of
people took it very seriously
and it seemed like we were gonna keep
having this raging economic situation
positive economic situation if we go now
to today we are basically eight to ten
weeks since that time period the most of
the government mandated shutdowns in the
United States started right in the
middle of March so call it eight weeks
since then and we've seen 36 million
Americans file for unemployment for
someone employment claims in the last
eight weeks that puts us into very deep
kind of unemployment percentages in many
ways to compare even worse than the
Great Depression we've seen GDP in
you one fall 4.8% that's pretty telling
given that only the last you know two to
four weeks really had pressure from the
virus and the economic side so q2 should
be much worse and then on top of that
we've seen literally tens of thousands
of small businesses around the country
mandated to shut down by the by the
government and so when I look at the
current situation you know I tend to
look at three key factors one is what is
the economic data saying - what is the
anecdotal information coming from the
operators on the ground and then three
what is the stock market or the public
markets saying kind of that the
speculators or the prediction market the
stock market you know provides and so
I'll walk through those three things
here I kind of give you an understanding
of how I'm analyzing you know both the
market and also various asset classes
before I forget I keep getting told make
sure that you like hit the little like
button on this video so more people can
watch it make sure you subscribe to the
channel and if you leave comments here
in the live chat I'll do my best to to
answer some of the questions after I get
talking for a little bit so going back
to those three things first let's start
with the economic data I already
mentioned 36 plus million Americans to
file for first-time unemployment
benefits in the last eight weeks really
really bad situation we have tens of
thousands of businesses that are
mandated shut down by the US government
or the state governments and and some of
those states are starting to come back
online other states are actually
extending the lock downs now so not a
good situation there if you look at GDP
down 4.8% in q1 likely to be worse in q2
and so what ultimately happens is you
have to remember that the economic data
we get it is a lagging indicator for the
reality on the ground right what I mean
by that is you only know about the
unemployment numbers that were filed
last week so at worst or at best you
have a one-week lag in the actual
unemployment claims on top of that you
don't get a very accurate representation
of kind of true unemployment so things
like freelancers gate workers
self-employed they're not eligible to
file front
I mean claims when you then look at
things like the people who want to file
but can't for certain reasons if you
look at things like workers who actually
have had their hours cut or maybe
they're working the same hours but their
pay has been cut all of these things
blend into the situation around
employment in the United States is much
much worse than 36 million Americans
having filed for unemployment
so back in March around March I think
22nd give or take a couple of days I
wrote a piece that basically said look
based on the very early data on the
unemployment claims I believe we are
headed to great depression levels of
unemployment by the end of q3 I
literally was laughed at when I wrote
this and I provided a bunch of math as
to how I thought that the travel and
hospitality industries were going to
contribute to this but also other areas
would get hit as well
well in hindsight I wasn't aggressive
enough fray my mistake was actually not
being more aggressive in the
understanding of the market and so what
we've seen is we've literally seemed
from going from about 5.4 million
Americans that were unemployed at the
end of February our three point five
percent unemployment rate we've now seen
that jump all the way into the double
digits we've seen over 36 million
Americans fall for someone employment
claims so that is a really really dire
situation at just 36 million that's
basically one in five people in the
labor force in the United States or
without a job right now now if you look
at GDP if only the last call it two to
four weeks really was affected by the
coronavirus that was not a lot of time
out of a 90 day period in q1 and so my
guess is that the q2 GDP numbers are
going to be horrific
and if coronavirus has taught us
anything it's that we actually
underestimate how bad the damage can be
and so if you think about q2 GDP numbers
well all of April we were on shutdown so
literally they're just the entire
economy ground to a halt in most of May
we're gonna be an economic shutdown in
most of the major areas for economic
activity in the United States and so it
would not surprise me to see us print a
negative 20 percent GDP number in q2
negative 20 percent GDP is off the
charts
completely unfathomable at the beginning
of this year but I'm becoming more and
more convinced that we're gonna see
negative twenty percent GDP in q2 for
this year which is absolutely
devastating on any way you cut that data
and on top of all of this we then get
into a conversation
well how many businesses are going to
come out the other side of it so first
bucket of what is the economic data
telling us economic data is telling us
it's really really bad economic
situation I actually think it's a
lagging indicator and it's under
estimating how bad the reality on the
ground is right so it's already bad
enough to look at the data but the
situation on the ground is even worse
than what that data is telling us so if
we go to bucket two and we look at okay
well if all of this economic data is
actually really bad why is the stock
market reckon the public market of the
prediction market provided by stocks
actually rallying why do we see stocks
going up but economic data getting worse
and the reality is that the stock market
is not a representation of the economy
the stock market is actually a
representation of central bank actions
especially during a time of crisis and
so if you go back to 2008 2009 when the
economic crisis happened all of a sudden
the government stepped in and said hey
we're gonna bring rates down in
emergency cuts we're also going to start
to print money and for the most part it
worked right and what I say it worked is
it worked for what they were optimizing
for they were optimizing for the least
amount of economic damage and the
fastest road to recovery they were not
optimizing for solving the economic
problems they were not optimizing for
actually helping make sure that the
structure of the US economy was
sustainable it was simply how do you
short-circuit a recessionary period and
get back to recovery and so what we saw
there was it worked if that's what you
were optimizing for well fast-forward
back to 2020 and all of a sudden we get
to this recessionary period and what do
you see rate cuts immediately to zero
you then see printing so far we've
printed a couple trillion dollars
there's a plan I missed working its way
through the government for another three
trillion dollars we'll see if it gets
passed or not but what ends up happening
is if this next plan or proposal gets
passed
the Federal Reserve balance sheet will
have doubled in the first half of this
year think about that for a second we
were at four trillion dollars give or
take on the Federal Reserve's balance
sheet we're now already over six choice
we've already had a 50% increase if they
pass another proposal we are likely to
get a doubling of the Federal Reserve
balance sheet in a single six-month
period absolutely crazy but that's what
the stock market is responding to the
stock market investors see oh wait a
second the government is stepping in
they've got lending programs they've got
all sorts of relief in aid packages and
they're going to print trillions of
dollars we know that that will devalue
the currency of their assets should
stabilize and eventually rise in price
so something like stocks I should be
buying stocks during that time period
and I'll get to why I actually think
that's a bad strategy in a little bit
but economic data looks bad stock market
recovering not recovering because of the
economic data recovering though because
they see the government stepping in and
they see that the government is going to
use a 2008 playbook of monetary policy
or a quantitative easing to try to
stabilize and drive recovery and markets
and short-circuit a recessionary period
so AC stocks going up then you get the
actual reality on the ground of the
third bucket and that third bucket is
the most important one so it's the
anecdotal stories and data points that
you see on the ground from actual
operators what that tells you is that
will give you the purest signal on to
what is actually happening in the US
economy and so a couple that I've seen
recently are things like there's a
coffee shop chain I forget the the name
of it they've been in business for over
30 years they have 50 locations and
today they announced that they're
shutting down right completely shutting
after 33 years of business a 50 chain
coffee shop is going to go ahead and
completely cease operations and shut
down their business that's not a
mom-and-pop shop right everyone's
worried about the small business on the
street corner it's got one location a
family runs it and they're hoping they
can get by we're talking about a 50
location chain coffee shop shutting down
Neiman Marcus JCPenney etc all filing
for bankruptcy right they cannot make
this work
then all of a sudden you start to see
all of the pressures when it comes to
commercial real estate you start to see
small businesses right that are actually
firing their employees and closing up
shop so here in New York City bunch of
restaurants have started to come out and
say look it was a great ride we really
appreciate all your guys support but
we're not coming back and so remember we
are only eight weeks in to this economic
crisis based on the government mandated
shutdown and so this is the most
important data point to me mainly
because I believe that it is
foreshadowing a much much dire situation
moving forward and what I mean by that
is if already eight weeks in we are
seeing 50 location coffee shops shut
down forever if we are seeing small
businesses shut down forever if we're
seeing large retail chains like the JC
Penney's the Neiman Marcus is that we're
already under pressure and now kind of
got that the knockout blow filed for
bankruptcy
this is going to get way WAY worse and
what I estimate is actually happening is
there's a bunch of business owners right
now that are saying they're holding on
for dear life they got some PPP money
from the government they got maybe some
revenue by trying to get to online
ordering or something like that and
they've been able to just kind of Coast
and barely make some of the payments
that need to make barely pay some
employees what ends up happening though
is as we get to the end of May and into
June I think that's when we're gonna
start to see really really large number
of businesses come out and say look I
lasted for 60 70 80 days that 90-day
mark is when you're gonna see a bunch of
them just give up right and they're
gonna say I can't make it out of this
thing and I don't think that the US
economy is gonna be wide open you know
by kind of the mid of the middle of June
in not in terms of policy of being open
but actually the velocity of money
rolling and and actually getting
economic activity back and so that
on-the-ground anecdotal data tells me
that we are actually going to have a
much dire situation ahead of us and it's
going to get worse before it gets better
and I'll give you a couple of kind of
ancillary impacts there so first of all
if all of a sudden let's say
fifteen to twenty percent right I wrote
about a month ago I think twenty percent
of small businesses are not coming back
from this right and these are you know
small businesses make up about fifty
percent of jobs in the United States
these are usually kind of one maybe two
or three locations usually kind of
family-run held for a long period of
time they have no kind of private equity
ownership or venture capital ownership
they're what you think of as a Main
Street business or a small business my
guess is that those businesses 20% of
them not coming back across all
industries doesn't matter if it's travel
hospitality or something else and so of
all of a sudden you get to a world where
twenty percent of those guys don't come
back if they are responsible for fifty
percent of jobs overgeneralization right
easy back of the napkin math that means
that 10% of total jobs the United States
just got eliminated in already eight
weeks or nine or in ninety days right
so if it ends up being true that 20% of
small businesses don't come out of this
ten percent of all jobs the United
States just evaporated right really
really bad we don't know that yet until
we start to see more and more of these
businesses bow out and say look like I
just can't make it and so I think that
that is one key pieces the second piece
of it is right now everyone is holding
on to the hope and dream that when the
state governors say we're opening up our
state there will be an explosion of
economic activity right all the pent-up
economic activity people want to go back
to restaurants they want to go into
movie theaters they want to travel they
want to go to the store and do all this
stuff warning be very very cautious when
we see the initial data when they reopen
these states right it's what I
previously described as a dead cat
bounce in the economic data so what do I
mean by that in China in Wuhan China we
saw in weeks five to nine after they
reopened the economy there was an
explosion and economic data and it Pete
and everyone said look we very quickly
within nine weeks reached the
pre-pandemic levels of our economic
activity well if you then go two weeks
11 12 13 etc now all of a sudden there's
a decrease in that economic activity and
so where it's basically stabilized is
they've lost about 20
percent of the economic activity
compared to pre-pandemic levels so what
you get is you get a big drop right
during the government mandated shutdown
you get this what looks like a v-shaped
recovery because you get an explosion of
the gate of all these people who rush
back to stores restaurants etc but then
after it stabilizes you actually have a
net loss of economic activity you're at
20% so imagine if you go back to
February and I said to you we are gonna
lose 20% of economic activity in the
United States you would think that that
was absolutely horrific right that would
be destabilizing that have all of these
repercussions well we're gonna get to
that point most likely it's just gonna
be hyper volatile in terms of a huge
draw down a huge recovery and then you
get that net loss and so I think that
what's gonna happen here is as small
businesses starts about a business as we
see more pressure on large corporations
as we see even more pressure on
commercial real estate right and States
start to reopen there's gonna be a lot
of noise but be warned that that dead
cat bounce is very likely we've seen in
other regions that have opened up and
simply it's because consumer behavior
has changed right I continue to ask
people how many of you are willing to go
sit right now in a super crowded
restaurant I'm not talking about hey you
go sit at a table with two friends and
there's somebody sitting at the table
next to you that to me is in crowded I'm
talking about walking into a New York
City bar where you use the stand
shoulder-to-shoulder I just don't see
that happening right how many of you are
willing to get on flights right now for
non-essential travel right if it isn't
work-related how do you want to go on
vacation right now right how many people
are actually going out and spending
money if they were able to on goods or
services right there's a lot of people
sitting at home who are sitting there
thinking I don't need all the things
that I previously thought I needed I
don't actually spend nearly the money on
the on the goods and services that I
thought I was doing and so I believe
that there will be a net loss in
economic activity coming out of this
which will be very detrimental now where
where does this mean for the stock
market right I continue to say that when
we see earnings for q2 it is going to be
a reality check to Wall Street now what
does that mean the reality check to Wall
Street right now is ever
is praying for one the central bank
actions to take hold and to drive this
recovery in the economy and two is
they're praying that that pent up demand
comes raging back right if you look at
something like the American box office
right I've talked about it before in the
third week of March of 2019 the u.s. box
office for movie theaters did over 200
million dollars in revenue the third
week in March of 2020 they did five
thousand dollars as an industry ninety
nine percent loss of revenue right
everyone is sitting there saying I think
it's coming back I think it's coming
back there's gonna be this massive
recovery there will be a reality check
when all of a sudden there isn't a
massive recovery in economic activity
and therefore I think that we will see
another pretty large leg down in the
public stock market I own no public
stocks I am NOT a stock picker I am NOT
a stock investor I just think when you
look at an economy and all of the moving
parts that make up the complexity of it
understanding where some of these
markets are going are really important
and so it would not surprise me one bit
to see a massive leg down in the stock
market this would be very similar to
what we saw in the Great Depression
right there was a drawdown there was a
relief rally and then there was a second
leg down we've seen that in other areas
and so that would not surprise me here
and I think that that catalyst for it is
going to be the shock to many investors
that there is not going to be this
v-shaped recovery in economic data like
they think that there's going to be it
ultimately it comes down to this we are
seeing the virus accelerate a lot of
trends that were already existent are
already kind of moving in the right
direction
and also the virus exposed a lot of
shams in the US economy and so simple
shams are things like corporate debt
loads right or the higher education
model if you look at retail physical
retail spaces right versus online
ordering if you look at things like our
supply chains all of these things are
now being exposed by this virus and so
when I had to moth come on the podcast
mouth pal uppity a--from social capital
buffer
point that previously the US economy was
driven through a search for efficiency
we wanted the lowest cost most efficient
processes and supply chains and
businesses but what we gave up in that
search for efficiency was a focus on
resiliency and because humans are humans
and we have recency bias and and this
will change the mindset of the
psychology of an entire generation of
people from investing and building
companies I think you're gonna see an
over rotation back and people are going
to seek to build resilient systems and
resilient companies well that means that
there will be a lack of efficiency or a
loss of efficiency as they go to get
that resiliency so you will see things
come back onshore from oversea you will
see consumer behavior change but I just
don't see it coming back nearly like I
think many people do and so if you walk
through the various asset classes kind
of how do I think this will play out I
think one the stock market there is a
massive massive dislocation between
reality on the ground and the stock
market numbers now this isn't rocket
science I'm not the only one saying this
if you guys hear that beefing that is
pulling a cooking in the kitchen she
says hello to everybody but basically if
you think of that economic data and
where the stock market is there's got to
be either a recovery and economic data
to meet the expectations of Wall Street
or there will be re pricing or price
discovery of the stocks to meet the
economic data I think the latter is much
more likely than the former if you look
at something like real estate we have
not yet seen massive correction in real
estate yet I believe that that is coming
but again if you are sitting there and
only eight weeks ago you were able to
sell your property or your building at a
certain cost eight weeks isn't enough
time to really think hey things have
changed
right and again you're holding onto the
belief that we're going back to the
world that we lived in and so I think
that there's gonna be a lot of kind of
slow you know deals being done there but
over time we will see there a market
correction in real estate prices both
commercial and residential and and that
will take time but when it happens it's
kind of a slowly but then all at once
and so once you start to see one two
three large players in a market crack
and start to lower prices or deals
actually get minted at lower prices then
you'll see an acceleration you'll see
every deal get done at that reprice kind
of market and so I think that's coming
oil I tend to think that all of the you
know kind of chaos in the oil market all
the geopolitical aspects that's gonna
continue to play out yes they are
promising to cut production but I do
believe that it will have some positive
impact with that said I do not think
that the economy is going to be opened
up fast enough to drive a drastic
recovery and demand for oil we're gonna
have the same problem that we for the
june futures contracts that physically
set up futures contracts that we had for
the mayonez a lot of the oil reservoirs
and storage is filled up and so what
ends up happening is there's just no
ability to store the oil nobody wants to
hold the contracts I wouldn't be
surprised if we see negative oil futures
contracts again for for those June
settlement dates I previously tweeted
and said I don't know if it's gonna go
negative a hundred right the class
summit looks like negative 50 give or
take but I do think that it's possible
and just the possibility of seeing a
negative hundred dollar futures contract
for oil being printed would is just
again unfathomable eight weeks ago now
you see a path to it while it might not
be probable it is possible which I think
is is pretty telling and then if you
look at things like gold Bitcoin other
inflation type assets I think that it is
very obvious that the central banks and
the US government has decided that
they're going to print their way out of
this and I find very difficult to
believe that history will not repeat
itself in the sense of one as they print
more and more money you are devaluing
the currency say it's absolutely
incredibly painful to the bottom 50% of
citizens but it enriches the top 50% we
can get into why that is but on top of
that you are going to see people fear
inflation so this is a key point
inflation doesn't actually have to occur
for inflation hedge assets to be
successful and to have high returns on a
kind of basis during the crisis you
simply have to have the fear of
inflation what do I mean by that if you
go back to 2008 gold went down 30% the
summer of 2008 when it dropped it was
during that liquidity crisis everyone
wanted to sell every asset they could
they were looking for dollars every
asset sells off and the dollar
strengthens gold was not safe during
that point he drew down 30% it then from
2008 to 2011 went up over 200% and ended
up hitting an all-time high but well
it's very interesting about that while
the government was printing money we
never actually got high levels of
inflation right because the deflationary
environment soaked up that liquidity but
the reason why gold performs so well
during that time period was because
there was a fear of inflation the
inflation never actually happened but
the fear was enough to actually push the
price of gold up I believe we will see
the same thing here I expect both gold
Bitcoin another inflation hedge assets
to do very very well as many people know
I think that one's gonna be the best
performer coming out of this crisis but
in simply the fear of inflation will
drive that activity it's not actually
inflation having to occur so that's it
for right now I have no clue how long
I've been 25 minutes or so nice little
monologue there I'm gonna go back and
try to answer as many of these questions
as I can I'll stay on for about 30
minutes or so so just fire off your
questions and I'll do do my best
the stock market is manipulated big-time
yeah look I think that this is a
no-brainer at this point the stock
market is manipulated through central
bank actions that the part to me that is
not concerning is central banks that is
their job I just use interest rates and
quantitative easing in order to manage
an economy they're technically not
supposed to be managing the stock market
they're supposed to be managing the
economy they're not supposed to be
managing a currency or stock market well
one we know that they di are paying it
into the stock market they continue to
make announcements you know the Fed made
a bunch of announcements I think was
Friday right a stock market closed like
they are definitely watching the stock
market and paying attention to that
stuff whether they want to admit it or
not the second piece of this is you by
definition you are
leading asset prices when you print
money right you were devaluing currency
and stabilizing an increasing stock all
room all asset prices but stock market
also and so by definition you are
manipulating the market you may say that
it is okay you are doing that but you
are manipulating the market what's more
concerning to me is the constant parade
of administration and kind of government
officials that go on television and try
to instill confidence in people so you
see everyone from larry cudlow to Jerome
Powell to the Treasury secretary etc
they continue to go on television and
say things like the US economy is strong
the US economy will recover you know
Larry Kudlow literally the beginning of
the crisis with some people to buy
stocks by the dip and then kind of
backtracked on those comments later for
the first time this past week we saw
Jerome Powell in the Federal Reserve
start to talk about wait a second this
is going to be bad right before it was
all about instill confidence instill
confidence now all of a sudden we're
starting to get a talk track that is
much more sobering drom piles actually
on 60 minutes tonight so it'll be
interesting to see what he says but my
guess is that now that they have
switched their talking points right if
you read what they're saying right now
and go back two weeks to what they were
saying it is a hundred eighty degree
difference before it was coronavirus is
real we have an economic slowdown there
will be a v-shaped recovery we will be
back now all of a sudden they're having
a much more sobering conversation and
the talking points are hey this is gonna
get bad yes the US economy is going to
suffer it's much worse than we thought
all of those types of talk talking
points that's have a manipulation I
think is very hurtful to investors but
but obviously it's the government they
can do they can do what they want um
let's see here I'm so old I remember
when being a millionaire meant you were
rich yes I also saw on Twitter today
somebody said at this rate we're all
gonna be billionaires right and
basically they're referencing if you
think of you know Zimbabwe I have a one
trillion dollar you know piece of paper
that that I carry around in my wallet
and and really it's just the idea that
as they print more and more money the
currency becomes devalued right that
currency as it gets devalued you need
more of it to buy the same goods right
you know I continue to point people to
look at what's happening in led
right now I think Lebanon is a great
example of what can happen if you are
not careful in these situations so for
those that are unaware Lebanon
previously there was a number of
government protests that were occurring
kind of pre-pandemic
the pandemic occurred they put a shelter
in place type order everyone went inside
including the protesters during that
time there's been incredible volatility
and debasement of the currency the the
Central Bank has done a fairly poor job
in controlling that that currency the
currency seen a massive drop against the
US dollar all of a sudden they start to
open up their economy and what are the
protesters say the protesters say hey we
were pissed off beforehand now we're
even more mad because now not only are
you actually you know mismanaging the
currency in the economy but now there's
capital controls in place so if I'm a
Lebanese citizen I go to the bank
they've put tons of restrictions on
withdrawals they also won't let me
withdraw on any currency other than the
Lebanese pound and then on top of all of
that food prices are soaring because
there's been a bunch of shutdown on the
pandemic side and so all of a sudden you
get a population of people that go to
sleep every night and when they wake up
they have to question can I afford food
right it has my wealth been devalued
away ready to imagine if you were
sitting there with the equivalent of ten
thousand US dollars in your bank account
and you woke up tomorrow and that ten
thousand dollars that used to buy you
one acre of land now only buys you half
an acre of land or a quarter of an acre
of land right you're your savings even
though the account says the same number
it's actually being devalued away so
that's one of the things happening there
massive social unrest I think that we
are going to see coming out of this
crisis incredible social unrest whether
it is physically demonstrated through
protests and other things in the streets
or it is done through digital means like
Twitter and others and coming out at oh
wait oh nine crisis a lot of people were
really upset with the u.s. gov the big
banks right it was all about the base
cause of crisis they're bad people
they're greedy they hurt the little guy
you know the the kind of Occupy Wall
Street Zuccotti Park all that kind of
stuff that was the sentiment coming out
of Alito not coming out of this I have
no doubt that people are gonna point and
say my government
is the reason that this all happened
right they're going to look at all the
data that is now servicing from the
virus right you know look I believe that
the virus is very real it is very
dangerous and tweeting today it is
possible to think that the virus is
dangerous it is possible to think that
we shouldn't overwhelm the healthcare
system it is possible to think that our
reaction has decimated the US economy
and it is possible to believe that the
data that is being reported is
inaccurate and it is possible to believe
that we should reopen our economy in a
safe and intelligent way and do it
quickly so it's possible to believe all
of those things most people that are
having this conversation though they
won't have a very binary conversation
pick the health care system or pick the
economy right they don't want to have
the nuanced conversation we have to
remember is the world's complex so what
does that end up meaning here's a great
stat for you the the numbers that I saw
recently are Los Angeles County right
one of the most populous counties in
America has 13 deaths that are
attributed to coronavirus now I'm not
here to say is that good or bad right I
don't know I'm not an epidemiologist I'm
not a healthcare professional that's
just the data that I read what I do know
is that as people see data like that
every single person in Los Angeles
County is gonna start to say wait a
second 13 people died I can't believe
that they decimated our economy over 13
deaths now part of the fallacy of that
argument is that we don't know what the
impact of social distancing was right
how what would it have been if we didn't
do social distancing if we didn't do
this shelter at home if we didn't shut
down businesses all of these different
things but what ends up happening is
because of the recency bias people feel
the economic impact there's only so many
families or individuals that knew those
13 people who died right but a hundred
percent of people saw the economic
carnage and so what you get is you're
gonna get this blaming of the the
government and then really is gonna be
the state governments I think where
people are gonna say hey my state
leaders or my local leaders or idiots
they blew up our economy it wasn't as
bad on the health care side as they told
us it was gonna be and therefore they
made mistakes right again unfair because
it's hard to tell what would have
happened if we didn't take these steps
but I think that that's a huge part of
this that's gonna end up happy
and we're just not ready really to uh to
do that yet um let's see here people are
staying home even without lockdown
orders people are scared institutions
aren't communicating clear truthful info
so people can assess your risks so I
don't know about the truthful part to
this I definitely agree that people are
staying home even without lockdown
orders we saw this before the lockdown
even started right which people were
basically told hate social distancing
work from home if possible all that kind
of stuff and so I think people are
changing their behavior obviously
putting the shelter in order places
really kind of accelerated that for
everybody I do agree that institutions
and/or politicians and leaders are being
really really bad at communicating right
and and there's two buckets to this for
me so one is a lot of the communication
I've seen from leaders only from the
national level down to the local level
is there's a political thing right the
number of deaths whether something is
open or not who gets funding all this
kind of stuff ends up being politicized
and so that just in general I think a
large portion of the population is tired
of hearing that stuff and they want the
economy turned back on and they want
people's lives saved right they don't
want that politics though so I think
that's kind of strike one strike two is
every single leader that I've seen their
actions don't match their works so I'll
give you two examples one is they go up
and they do these press conferences and
they don't have masks on right today
today I saw a photo literally of Andrew
Cuomo in New York he was getting a
corona virus test they were literally
putting it in his nose the person
administering that test had gloves on
had a surgical gown they had a mask on
themselves and then they had the
healthcare shield and they were giving
the test to the governor of New York
State and the governor of New York State
had no personal protective equipment on
and so what an image like that tells
people is you're telling me to wear a
mask but you don't have a mask on again
it doesn't mean that masks aren't
helpful right I actually think that
masks are helpful but what it tells them
is you think that you are better than us
you think you are higher than us you
think that you are above the rules
you're doing things you're telling us to
do things that you're not willing to do
yourself so I think that's kind of step
one where people are really looking at
their leaders and saying why are you
asking us to do things that you you're
so
armie been doing the second thing then
is when it comes to finances so I've
said from the very beginning that if I
was the governor of a state the first
thing that I think that they should do
is they should give up their salary for
as long as they keep small businesses
closed in their state why it's not
because of any reason other than you
immediately say to small business owners
I'm in this with you right as long as
you suffer I'm going to suffer and as
you're a leader I'm never going to ask
you to do something that I'm unwilling
to do myself but that's not what we're
seeing
instead we literally are seeing our
politicians continue to take paychecks
Wow our small business owners and
employees of a lot of these businesses
are actually being told you are not
legally allowed to operate your business
you cannot actually go to work and so I
think that that's a huge mistake there
in terms of the leadership I don't know
why
polina is basically has like a fire
going on over here well house prices
dump at Christmas I don't know if house
prices are gonna dump at any specific
time but I definitely think that on the
real estate side we're gonna see three
things happen I'll start with the
commercial side then go to residential
so on the commercial side I think you're
gonna there's three arguments right now
one is that people are going to
completely get rid of their offices and
go 100 percent remote one is people are
going to keep the amount of space that
they currently have and or downsize so
they're going to take into account some
of these you know coronavirus type
things and basically change the way that
they use space and then three is
somebody like eric schmidt from google
who believes that actually people are
going to rent more space in the
commercial side so they can allow for
social distancing and other things I
don't think the third option is very
viable I think that one of the first two
options is much more viable and so we've
already seen a number of businesses
start to say hey look we don't need
space we're gonna go hundred percent
remote we were forced to do this it
actually went pretty well we're gonna
continue to do this for a save a bunch
of money another option is people are
either gonna change the layouts of their
office or there's gonna need less space
because some of their employees will
work from home while some still go into
an office and so I think that you'll see
kind of that price pressure happen as
these economies start to reopen people
start going back to work you'll see
people start breaking leases not not
re-upping for leases and so that
commercial
we'll probably happen over the next 12
to 18 months when you go to the
residential side well one is if your
business starts to go in is completely
remote now I'm not physically tied to
any one place I can live wherever I want
so take a place like New York City why
am i paying you know a higher rate of
rent if I no longer have to go to the
office for my business I can go move to
any other place in the world really and
just work remotely now it starts to
create all kinds of pressure on
residential real estate as well and so I
think I saw recently that vacancies are
an all-time high or at least a local
high in New York City
also new rentals so kind of the rate at
which places are being rented out is is
also very high or is very low right so
basically that there's a lot of pain
going on there and so I think that what
you'll see is in the residential market
outside of the major metros you will
start to see some areas get decimated
people just want to move out of
high-cost areas you know San Francisco
for example I just don't see those
housing prices stay high like they have
been what other places will benefit
right so think of you know your states
with little to no state income tax
places that have nice weather all of
that kind of stuff if all of a sudden I
can choose where I want to live and I'm
not tied to it based on an occupation I
do believe that you'll start to see some
some changes they're both positive and
negative but I don't think is gonna
happen for Christmas I think it'll
happen some other time all right so a
lot of people asking about the Fed and
the Fed chair here's what I would love
to say is I think that it's an
impossible job right I don't think that
this part has really ever talked about
enough but I think that being the Fed
Chairman is an impossible job especially
in times like this because you'll never
get it right right there's too many
complex components of the US economy for
you to get it right
really what you basically are trying to
do is you're trying to make as least
mistakes as possible and so I you know I
think that they are optimizing you know
again you got to go back to what are
they optimizing for they are there to
manage an economy they're not there to
manage your currency they're not there
to manage the stock market they're there
to manage Makana me and so part of
managing economy is
making sure that there's as least damage
as possible on the downside but what
that does is it short circuits the
recessions over the depressions and it
doesn't change the structural issues
right you know right now if you go to
the federal relief programs for example
one of the things that just cracks me up
is part of the loan process has been
that there are companies about to go out
of business right so whether we think
that it's fair or not companies that
have been bad capital allocators or
about to go out of business and all of a
sudden we are going to hand bad capital
allocators taxpayer money right now
again that's a huge overgeneralization
but I do think that in a true market
cycle where a downturn would wipe out
some percentage of businesses that
aren't healthy aren't sustainable aren't
good businesses and then allow new
entrants into markets right new
competition and kind of rebuilding of an
economy in an up cycle in a market when
you go ahead and you print a bunch of
money you hand it to everybody what you
basically do is you short-circuit that
you don't allow for the clearing out of
the bad businesses and therefore you end
up having some issues over a long period
of time so it's a hard job but I do
think that it is it's gonna be pretty
ridiculous in terms of the impact here
the other thing that I will say is it is
quite comical also to me that in the
latest I think it's the house proposal
the three trillion dollar stimulus
package that has been proposed we have
seen things like there's three trillion
dollars in the program a trillion of it
is for state and local governments right
so literally they're going to print a
trillion dollars and they're going to
hand it to the worst capital allocators
in the world governments and they're
gonna do that and there's not a lot of
checks and balances in place there so a
trillion dollars gets printed and handed
all these governments and the way it
gets handed out is not very well
understood yet I have no doubt that
there's gonna be financial incentives
tied to kovat impact which then again
has a circular impact on well if all of
a sudden I'm a state governor and the
amount of money I get from the federal
government to bail me out is depending
on how many couvade deaths or infections
I have that
I mean financially incentivized to
inflate that number as high as possible
and so I think that you're gonna see a
lot of that it would not surprise me
what one thing that I do think is going
to happen in the future that I haven't
talked about this yet I do believe that
there will be some sort of corruption
investigation at the state level I don't
know what state it is but there will be
some sort of corruption investigation
based on Co vid data reporting right and
so whether that is hospitals inflating
numbers so that they can get money
whether that is cities or states or some
there's gonna be some sort of audit at
some point and there will definitely be
nefarious or bad activity going on there
and that doesn't necessarily mean that
they're all overinflating there actually
could be under accounting intentionally
right for some financial reasons as well
and so I do think that that's likely to
to occur as well let's see here yes the
the rich get richer and the poor get
poorer so this is the this is my main
concern with all of this right I think
it's really important to talk about is
whenever you print money you basically
are widening the wealth and equality gap
right the way that that works is the
bottom 50% of Americans give or take
they live paycheck to paycheck and they
have no investments in real assets right
so you've everyone's heard the stats you
know they can't afford $400 emergency
payment forty five percent of Americans
don't own a stock whether it's in a
brokerage account or any sort of
retirement account all these kind of
things and so the IMF wrote a paper in
the late 90s basically said inflation is
the number one cause of wealth
inequality or one large drivers and
that's really for two reasons one is Adi
values the money so if you were sitting
there and you only have four or five
hundred dollars in your bank account
every year your your savings you don't
have a lot is being devalued away so
that four or five hundred dollars can
buy less and less year after year you
don't own any real assets on top of that
is many of the people in the bottom half
of the country do not have inflation
adjusted wage contracts so what that
basically means is let's say you have a
white-collar job you get paid you know
seventy thousand dollars a year every
year your salary goes up to two and a
half percent simply as an inflation - or
as a
to inflation and therefore you never see
the impacts on your pay or you're
getting paid more and more every year to
account for that well that person that
gets paid you know ten twelve dollars
now or they're getting paid ten dollars
now or a year after year after year they
think they're making the same amount of
money but actually the purchasing power
that they're receiving from their
employer is going down because they're
not getting that adjustment for
inflation year after year and so what
that leads to is this massive wealth
inequality gap and the bottom 50%
actually get poor overtime on the flip
side what is inflation do it drives
asset prices right if you ever look at a
chart what is the stock market it's just
literally up into the right at a
45-degree angle over a long period of
time right producer every other asset
class same thing why because of
inflation right in some cases yes the
businesses are getting more valuable but
also you're seeing a devaluation of the
currency that is priced in write a new
Act if you take something for example
like the US dollar and say what is the
S&P 500 denominated in dollars it's up
into the right at a 45-degree angle if
you then take that same S&P 500 but you
say what is it in denominated in Bitcoin
it's actually down at a 45 degree angle
down into the right now why is that well
because one of those assets is an
inflationary asset the other is a
deflationary asset so it's really
important to always understand that part
of the asset prices that you're seeing
or the movement you're seeing is driven
by the currency in which it's priced
right and obviously the stock market
with dollars and so I think that what
happens here is rich people basically
know they know the game right I always
say there's kind of four rules to
getting rich right one is to have
multiple streams of income second rule
is to make us to spend less than you
make third is to get out of inflationary
assets into deflationary assets and
fourth is to stay patient and be
disciplined right it's pretty simple
those are the four rules to get rich
rich people know and so the number three
rule is really really important they get
out of currency and they get into real
assets they own real estate they own
stocks right they own commodities etc
and so that as that currency gets
devalued they see their asset prices
rise they actually are getting rich
during this right if you think about it
the top fifty five percent of Americans
actually own stocks they're super
excited when they see that money printer
start right that's why stocks are
rallying they're buying because they see
hey there's going to be a road to
recover
so I think that's where you see kind of
the rich get richer and the poor get
poorer during these times that shouldn't
be a be a surprise to too many people
let's see I live in Berlin Germany where
things officially reopened this week how
are things just seem a lot less active
than before restaurants look almost
empty there's not just that many people
outside yeah so I think this is a good
example right everything's gonna be
anecdotal for the next couple of weeks
until we get hard data but I do believe
that even though places are open right
you know here in the United States for
example there's telling restaurants that
they can open with twenty-five to fifty
percent of capacity in many places so
you know I read an article that people
are literally putting mannequins in the
restaurants and dressing them up so
doesn't seem like creepy which I don't
know if it's more creepy that the
mannequins are there or that the tables
would be empty but with that said if you
think of a restaurant for example you're
now saying okay you're not shut down so
the federal relief is likely to end for
you and will let you open up but you can
only open up at twenty five to fifty
percent of capacity most restaurants
that economics don't work right they
need to be open up at a hundred percent
capacity they can't do it at 50 percent
of capacity and so actually what may
happen is by having a kind of a slow
rollout or kind of this staged reopening
of economies and capacity constraints
and things like that you actually may
kill more businesses by not simply just
reopening to everybody obviously there's
health concerns with it so there's a
balance but but it doesn't surprise me
that restaurants look almost empty you
know and there's just not that many
people outside I think I'll have the
same thing here in the US hopefully that
doesn't happen but but I think that's
where we're we're doing Israel
relatively open due to good response but
demand for services and products is low
negative 25 percent unemployment yeah I
mean look we're gonna see this kind of
entire story all around the world right
I don't think that matters you know if
you're in the West if you're somewhere
in the Middle East if you're Europe in
Asia it's just human psychology right is
you just spent weeks and weeks and weeks
sitting at home and having the
government your government tell you it's
bad don't go outside you'll die if you
go outside all this kind of stuff and
now all of a sudden they're like okay go
back outside it's like what you know
imagine if you were a kid right and your
parents said hey don't go in that room
you know if you go in there you might
die right they kept telling that
telling you kept telling you that and
then one day they said okay you go in
the room well you might go open the door
you might kind of peek inside right he
might tiptoe inside but you're I'm just
gonna open the door go running inside
and like hope nothing bad happens right
same thing here and so will that be it
you know kind of the the human
psychology forever I don't think so I do
think that there at some point we will
get back to some feeling of normalcy
it still won't kind of show for many
years of full return on the economic
data side but but there's a
psychological scar here in terms of the
way that people are going to interact
with others I mean come to the places
they go additionally I think that
there's a psychological scar on
investors and operators in that now
you're gonna start to hear people
talking about not is my business
recession-proof but is it pandemic proof
you're gonna start having investors talk
about well how long can you go with zero
dollars in revenue all of that kind of
stuff I think will play into that
and then lastly another key piece of
this is a plan is making chicken wings
that she's super excited over here
squirt and her barbecue sauce but but on
on top of that I think that another
aspect that that's gonna be really
interesting to watch is just how many
people are willing to change the way
that they earn money right if you think
about this I said this previously that
if you want kind of true freedom
financial freedom and and and freedom in
your life one of the best things you can
do right now is learn how to make a
living with only an internet connection
right so forget going in some way or
forget any physical products forget all
of this stuff all of that stuff just got
taken away but this digital economy I
think you're gonna see a lot of people
start to say wait one of the ways I need
a pandemic proof my my salary my
livelihood is I need figure out how to
make money with only an internet
connection and so that wouldn't be
surprising to what to see I kind of
accelerated overtime as well well look
at these questions remember hit the like
button on the video so more people can
see this make sure you subscribe to the
channel as well
I keep getting people texting me telling
me to tell you that to everybody see
here yes opening up look there's no
magic pill to how we open up the
economies but I do think that it's
important
in terms of the way it's done I do think
that there is a path where you can say
our hospitals have not been overwhelmed
but we're still worried about it
potentially happening if we do this
incorrectly
we believe that masks hand-washing and
social distancing are important and
therefore we are going to completely
open up 100% of our economy but we are
going to be very fanatical about you
know the masks and the social distancing
and all of these types of things my
guess is that you'll get some economic
activity coming back some relief it
won't be nearly what we need but I
definitely think that that is as
possible somebody said I work as a
security at a hospital and there are way
more couvade cases happening because
they get $39,000 if they have a
respirator I wish I owned a hospital I
don't know you know kind of what the the
validity of that is or isn't but I
definitely know that there's some
financial incentives for for having a a
co-ed patient do I think that the
government will transition to a gold
standard I think that there is nearly 0%
chance that the government is going to
transition to a gold standard I think
that what we are seeing is we are seeing
the playbook that every great dynasty
has implemented in order to ultimately
shoot themselves in the foot and fall I
do not see that on the short-term
horizon for the United States but this
is what every single great dynasty has
done they have devalued their currency
to the point of economic weakness and
then they have seen somebody else come
in either through invasion or just the
threat of invasion and ultimately become
a military superior country and
ultimately then take over as a global
superpower and implement their national
currency as the global reserve currency
I tend to think that that's what we are
we're doing here it's sad it's scary but
but I think that's kind of what's
playing out I've in terms of Bitcoin
I've talked a lot about this idea that I
do think that there is a paradigm shift
when it comes to global reserve
currencies and military might if you
think about in the analog world the way
that you get to have
the global reserve currency is you use
bombs bullets and soldiers you go and
you invade somewhere you kill people you
be sure that you have the most military
might and therefore you are the global
superpower just the threat of you going
and doing that to other countries they
said come to you they allow you to
install their your currency as the
global reserve currency and that's how
it's worked for thousands of years the
only difference is now war is going to
be fought in cyberspace in many cases
and so in cyber whereas in the analog
world having the offense makes you the
strongest military actually in cyber
it's having the greatest defence will
make you the strongest military and so
if you think about Bitcoin it has the
strongest computer network in the world
and therefore it is most resilient to
attack and therefore I think that
there's a possibility that Bitcoin will
over a number of years it's not gonna
happen the short term ultimately rise to
become the global reserve currency
because it will have the strongest
military in cyber terms right from a
defense standpoint and it'll have been
able to do that without shooting a
single bullet drop the bomb or use any
soldiers which will be pretty
interesting I'm gonna take two more
questions here and then I'm gonna go eat
some dinner so let's see here yeah so
somebody said I start a new Etsy store
and going very well first of all
congratulations second of all I think
that this is going to be a really
important conversation so first of all I
would tell people is you are responsible
for your own life right it is your
responsibility to make a living take
care of your family and ultimately be
happy I think there's a lot of people
looking around right now saying well the
government's not doing this from here
the government's not doing that or I
want to blame this person or blame that
person or or whatever but ultimately
you're responsible for your own life and
so what I mean by that is you have to
educate yourself with the skills
necessary to make a living and so you go
back to this idea of if you want true
freedom go figure out how to make a
living using an internet connection
exclusively right if you can use an
internet connection and make money then
you have true freedom and you can live
where you want you can do what you want
you can make your own hours you can do
all this stuff
the problem is many people don't have
that skill set and so I think that
there's going to be a explosion of
people interested in this they're going
to go figure out how to
get the skills to build digital
businesses everything from content
production to selling goods online to
building SAS products or writing
software all that kind of stuff but I do
believe that while people have been
sitting at home for the last eight weeks
give or take there's a lot of people who
are contemplating do I actually want to
do what I've been doing right or do I
want to go pursue a different career and
so I think that that's the type of stuff
that people are going through right now
and they're going to spend a lot of time
getting those digital skills necessary
in order to go ahead and you know make a
living with just an internet connection
only okay so there's two questions here
I'm going to kind of combine them so how
considerate of you about inflation you
see people buying inflation hedge assets
but you see other investors talking
about deflation and do you think the
stock market will crash this year in
some weird world I must say yes to all
three of these and so what do I mean by
that I am concerned about inflation over
a long period of time I think that there
is going to be a deflationary period in
the short to medium term and I believe
that the stock market will have another
correction this year now how does all of
this happen so first of all we had the
massive drop in the stock market we
didn't have the relief rally for anybody
who pays attention to kind of the
various retracement lines and things
like that I think it went right back to
like a it was 68 or 82 percent attrition
or whatever the hell it is people way
smarter than me you know helped me with
also basic observe or trace meant right
to that likely that it will turn over
and fall again and that's mainly because
the economic data on the ground is a
complete separation from the stock
market right there's a dislocation
between the two of them so I do think
there's gonna be correction now part of
what that relief rally has been is been
the printing of money and like I said
the stock market is a representation of
the central bank action it's not the
economy and so over a long period of
time it's just it's literally just math
you cannot print money and not get
inflation at some point you can't not
devalue a currency but over a long
period of time the US government's done
a pretty good job of preventing that
from getting into a hyperinflation
situation like a Venezuela Zimbabwe you
name your favorite dictators playground
so with that said I
you worry about the inflation over a
longer period of time but I do think
that the deflationary environment we are
in right now will continue for some
period of time was short to medium term
and so in a world where somebody like a
Paul Tudor Jones is positioning himself
to mitigate the effects of inflation but
Drunken Miller and others are
positioning themselves to take advantage
of the deflationary environment I think
that's actually both right there just
right on different time horizons and
part of that is the Federal Reserve
understands and even the Treasury etc
they understand that the dollar
continues to strengthen asset prices
have sold off the only way you're going
to eventually get asset prices to
sustainably recover is you're gonna have
to systematically weaken the dollar and
the way you do that is you print money
right and so I don't think that we the
printing is done again like I said
Federal Reserve balance sheet
fortunately in dollars at the beginning
of this year give or take it's over six
trillion now 50% increase I think that
they're gonna go ahead and I jokingly
said this but I'm becoming more
convinced that three trillion dollar
spending plan that was recently proposed
and passed in the house I know that the
Republicans are saying that they don't
want it all this kind of stuff but I do
think that we are going to see trillions
more printed and we will get a doubling
of the Federal Reserve balance sheet
this year and so ultimately you end up
getting inflation long term but the
deflationary environment will eat up a
lot of that in short term we live in a
crazy crazy crazy world I really want to
just leave everyone with this message of
like I cannot hammer at home enough the
number one thing that I think people
should be doing right now is learning
and what I mean by that is if you are
interested in the economy or financial
markets
it doesn't matter your age you are
getting a crash course in crisis in
human psychology or on investing in
Federal Reserve actions in repo markets
in quantitative easing monetary policy
all these different things educate
yourself and pay attention make sure you
are paying attention to what is going on
you are getting a free class in what
happens in these scenarios they only
come around so often really the last one
in a material size was back in 2008-2009
so you literally had to wait 10 to 12
years to actually get this class
pay attention make sure you're taking
the time to educate yourself make sure
you're trying to talk to as many smart
people as you can
write down what you're actually thinking
about right on whether it's daily or
weekly basis how are you feeling where
do you think asset prices are going how
do you actually evaluate kind of the
markets themselves the central bank
actions all that kind of stuff I think
is really really important because that
crash course is you know it only comes
around you know once a decade or so with
that said you were also responsible for
your life and so taking personal
accountability or responsibility is
incredibly important if you're able to
do that you'll have a significant
advantage both in life and in these
situations understand that people are
going to be highly highly emotional
they're gonna be highly highly
psychologically weak and so you will see
things like massive panics when prices
fall
you see massive FOMO when prices rise
and recoveries that we recently saw in
stock market that is going to permeate
into other asset classes as well whether
it is you know oils physically settled
future contracts whether it's things
like gold in Bitcoin or even real estate
and so understanding the human
psychology around investing is really
important make sure you're controlling
your psychology your emotions walk away
from the screen is super important to
doing all of this and just generally try
to understand that all this will pass
right we will get back to some level of
normalcy at some point in the future
there might be some pain there might be
some volatility between now and then but
ultimately we will get back there and so
before I leave you with that point that
they want you to come and say hello for
two seconds she's gonna make an
appearance there is chef Polina her hair
starting to look like mine that's why I
have hat on so we will we'll leave you
guys with that please like the video so
more people can see this make sure
you're subscribed to the channel so that
you get notifications when all of the
videos come out I appreciate all the
questions I appreciate all you guys
watching and I will do this again in the
future see you guys later